All righty then, it's time for "Drew's News",
your daily pop, pop, pop of the good news bubble wrap.
And with me at the desk, my little bubblicious,
effervescent co-pilot, Ross Matthews.
Pop, pop, pop.
(audience applauding)
Hi, everybody. Hi.
That's right, pop, pop, pop.
(audience applauding)
That is so satisfying.
The bubble wrap?
Yeah.
I still do it, I'm 42 years old.
Do you guys still do it when you get that bubble wrap?
Pop, pop, pop, pop.
(audience applauding)
So satisfying.
Well make sure you stick around to the end of the show,
because we have another blood pumping round of "Pop Quiz".
Oh, I love a pop quiz!
(bell rings)
(audience applauding)
That's right.
Pay attention everyone,
because one lucky member of our audience
is gonna be put to the test.
We'll ask you three questions about today's show
and if you get it right,
you're gonna win a thousand dollars.
(audience applauding)
We're gonna give it away.
Just give it away.
Yeah, I know.
I'm so excited, I love when people win.
Okay, first up we've got People's latest cover boy.
Oh, no.
Here it is.
Here we go.
(Ross laughs)
It's Stanley Tucci.
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
There's an interview
where Stanley talks about beating cancer
and how his friends and his wife, Felicity
got him through it.
And he talks about being a sex symbol at age 61.
He says, "It's so wonderful."
He says, "I don't quite get it, but I'm very glad."
And people wanna hoochie coochie with the Tucci.
And how cool that at 61 Stanley Tucci is now a sex symbol.
And you know what that means you guys.
In like 20 years,
you're all gonna be fantasizing about this, okay.
I'm telling you.
(audience applauding)
We already are.
Trend alert.
Stay tuned.
Okay, next up,
we all know the Brits love their high tea, right?
But it was an American who just managed to host
the highest, high tea on record.
Listen to this, CNN Travel reports,
Andrew Hughes hosted a tea party
at the very tippy-top of Mount Everest.
Yeah.
The tea and cookies at 21,312 feet.
He said he missed his climbing community
so much during the pandemic,
they swore that when they could get back together
they'd do something special.
So, he decided tea on the mountain top.
And he even managed to haul Girl Scout cookies
all the way from Seattle.
He purchased them from the Girl Scout Troop 6000,
the troop that serves young girls right here
in New York city's shelter system.
Yeah.
I mean,
(audience applauding)
the top of Mount Everest.
I read this story
that he had tea at the top of Mount Everest,
and you know what I thought about?
What?
Me last weekend in a hotel, Uber Eats ordering Starbucks,
because I was too lazy to even get out of my hotel room.
And this man's on the top of Mount Everest?
I know, I love also like the question of
"Would you climb Everest for a thin mint?"
(Ross laughs)
I love it.
Me too.
All right, well, next up we've got a brand new
food holiday coming to New York city this Sunday.
It's today's "Food News".
(audience applauding)
Nice!
All right, this story is very personal for me.
VegNews reports that New York
is joining 40 other cities and states
declaring March 20th, "Meat Out Day".
So, to celebrate you just drop the meat for one day
and explore the awesome world
of plant-based foods out there.
The holiday was declared by Mayor, Eric Adams
who is also responsible, and this was news to me,
making Mondays meatless at all 1,700 public schools
in New York city.
I didn't know that.
Yes.
That's very cool.
(audience applauding)
That's a revelation and a revolution!
And you know what?
Here to celebrate our own meatless menu,
please welcome all the way from Quorn Headquarters,
my best friend, Chicken!
(audience applauding)
(Drew screaming)
Oh, hi!
(audience applauding)
Oh, my gosh, what did you bring?
Oh, my gosh, Chicken.
This is my best friend, everybody.
We just did a commercial together and we are best friends
and we're go-
Yeah, that's our commercial right there, Chicken!
Oh, look at you.
Look there we are!
Chicken are you excited about "Meat Out Day?
(audience applauding)
I am too.
Here, Chicken.
Oh, I want one.
(audience applauding)
And that's the line at the end of our commercial,
because you wouldn't eat your best friend.
Aww.
Oh, these are Quorn's meatless nuggets
and I'm actually their CMO, chief mom officer.
But I'm a partner now there,
because I believe so much in their product.
Drew, I'm sold.
Get your own.
(audience applauding)
Oh, my gosh.
(upbeat music)